[موسيقى]
ليس من الضروري ان ترتكب في مكان معزول او
زقاق مظلم وليس من البديهي ان يكون
المعتدي مجهولا عنيفا او مس ل حن فكثيرا
ما يكون مسرح الجريمه هو فراش الزوجيه
والجاني هو المسمى فارس الاحلام وحين يكون
الزوج هو المعتدي تجمل الجريمه وتتحول الى
شان خاص او مشكل
اسري الاغتصاب الزوجي استنكر البعض هذا
المصطلح فقالوا كيف لسيده ان ترفض علاقه
جنسيه مع زوجها بدون عذر لما تقصر في
واجبها انها ناشز وهذا حقه الشرعي في
المقابل علت اصوات اخرى ترفض تسخيف
الجريمه وتدفع نحو محاسبه قانونيه وتدعو
الى كسر الصمت المخيم على عنف غرف النوم
على قاعده ان الاغتصاب واحد وان للزوجه
الحق بان تقول لا للجنس مع شريكها في فلك
الممنوع ببعض الحالات عندها ح اوقات بكون
مثلا سك تايم اوقات مريضه تعبانه ف
اكيد بحق مو مجرد مثلا نرجسيه او مزاجيه
من عندها ترفض لان هي بدايه بعقد الزواج
ينص انه هي تقبل تجامع الرجل بكل الاوقات
يفترض انه المراه تسهل لزوجها هالموضوع
هذا ما تصعب حتى مع وجود عقد زواج او بدون
عقد زواج هذا الشي لازم يكون ضمن رغبه
الشخصين الجنسين على هذا الاساس بتم
المعاشره الجنسيه غير هيك يعني بصير
اغتصاب بكون الرجال بس بده ياخذ مت
الشخصيه عرفت والمراه ماها نفسها عليه هذا
اغتصاب انا بعتبر مادام معرسين معناها
قضيه الاغتصاب عاش معناها ما بتسم قضيه من
اصم هم معرسين معنا من حقها بالدين بقول
هيك كل الاديان لا ما يحق لها لان هو
زوجها وابو بيتها واحنا نجي من مبدا
الاسلامي ان الرجال قومو على النساء اذا
كان هي رفضت يلزمه يسيرها في الرفض اعها
ما ما يرغمها من حق
لا ما يحق لها ما بحق لها لانه هذا حقه
دينا وشرعا اذا يعني ما صارت المعاشره فهو
راح يلتجئ الى هوايه
امور الاغتصاب الزوجي في فلك الممنوع
والبدايه من المغرب مع الناشطه الحقوقيه
فدوى رجوان اهلا بك سيده فدوى استمعت معنا
الى اراء الشارع لماذا برايك في عام 2023
لا يزال الاغتصاب الزوجي تابو ولا يزال
هناك من يدافع عن نظريه الواج الزوجي هناك
اصوات اليوم تتجر وتاخذ مبادره حديث عن
هذا الموضوع المسكوت عنه داخل البيوت
الزوجيه تتبعت معكم الروبورتاج رايتم كيف
ان
هناك
مصطلحين يتنافسان الحق والواجب الحديث عن
معاشره الزوجيه هي حق للرجل وواجب على
النساء وكان النساء لا رغبه لا رغبات لهن
لا يشتهين لا يمكن ان يرفض وحتى اذا رفض
فيجب ان يكون السبب مقنعا ان يكون هناك
مرض او تعب ويجب على الزوجه ان تحاول قدر
الامكان تسهيل الزوج تسهيل العمليه
الجنسيه للزوج هذا في نظري هو تراكم
لثقافه
ذكوريه هيمنت واستحوذت حتى على عقول
النساء لوات انفسه يعتبرنا ان ما يقوم
النبي حين
يرفضن هو غير جائز شرعا ربما حرام وقد
يدفع الزوج الى البحث عن تلبيه رغبات
الجنسيه خارج اطار الزواج وهنا تقع هذه
المعاشره التي اسميها انا اغتصابا نفسيا
تحت التهديد لان اذا ما لم تقدم هي هذه
المعاشره الجنسيه فهناك من هنا مستعدات
لتقديمها حتى خارج اطار الزواج اذا كل هذه
الامور وكل هذه الضغوطات تستحضرها النساء
في تلك
اللحظه يرغمن انفسهم احيانا على الاستمرار
وعلى تلبيه رغبه الزوج حتى لو يكنا راغبات
في ذلك طبعا الحديث عن الامور
مازال تقريبا ممنوعا عيبا
شومه ثم هناك
ايضا يعني الثقل الديني في هذا الموضوع
الذي يتحدث عن نشاء
الزوجه سننتقل الى هذه التفاصيل لاحقا
يعني عن مجموعه العناصر ربما التي تجعل من
هذا الموضوع تبوء اكثر من من مساله
الاغتصاب عندما يكون الاغتصاب متعلق بشخص
غريب او من خارج العائله ساذهب الى مصر مع
المحامي بالنقد الاستاذ عصام عجاج اهلا بك
استاذ عصام بدايه سؤالي لك انت كشخص يعني
من عالم القانون من محامي هل انت مع تجريم
الاغتصاب الزوجي ان يصبح الاغتصاب الزوجي
يعني مجرما في قوانين الاحوال المدنيه ام
انك تعتبر ان ان في الدول العربيه لانه
مجرم في دول اخرى في
العالمم انك تعتبر اليوم ان الاغتصاب
الزوجي غير موجود ربما كما يقول يقول
البعض انا اول اعتراض ل على كلمه الاغتصاب
الزوجي اصلا المفروض مافيش حاجه اسمها
الاغتصاب الزوجي الاغتصاب وفقا لكافه
القوانين مش قوانين العربيه بس لكافه
القوانين هو اكراه اكراه انثى على
المعاشره الجنسيه وبالتالي يجب ان تكون
اجنبيه عن الفاعل اللي هو الشخص اللي اقام
هذه العلاقه وبالتالي لا يمكن ان تسمى
اغتصاب زوجي اذا سميناها باغتصاب زوجي
لرجل على زوجته اللي هو اللقاء الحميمي او
المعاشره الجنسيه نقدر نقول عليها بلا
مبالغه من العبس والهزل امور عبسيه هزليه
وبالتالي لا يجوز ان احنا نسميها الاغتصاب
الزوجي هذا ام لي هناك من يعاشر زوجته
بالاكراه برايك يعني ليس هناك من يعاشر
زوجته
بالاكراه لا انا انا ماتكلمتش في ده انا
بقول ده ممكن يكون واقع من الناحيه
الواقعيه في بعض الحالات ممكن الرجل يعاشر
زوجته بالاكرام لكن نقدر نقول عليه اكرا
اكراه اكراه لا لا ما نقولش عليه اغتصاب
نقول عليه اكراه على المعاشره الجنسيه
وبالتالي لا يمكن ان احنا نرتقي بهيه
لدرجه ان احنا نحدد ل عقوبه ليه لانها شخ
لانها ليست اجنبيه عنه وبالتالي هتيجي
تقولي لي طيب ازاي رجل شرقي يعمل كده مع
زوجته وهي اصلا
مالهاش عايز اقول رغبه في هذه العلاقه
اقدر اقول لك من باب الموده من باب الفضل
من باب الرحمه من باب الكياسه من باب
الفطنه سميها من اي باب يجب على الرجل الا
يعاشر زوجته الا اذا كانت راغبه في ذلك
ولكن اذا حدث هذا ام اذا حدث هذا من الزوج
لا يجوز لا يجوز حط تحتيها 20 سطر ان
يعاقب الزوج بجريمه او ان نسمي هذا جريمه
الاغتصاب الزوجي طيب سيدي بقد اريد ان
الفه النظر ركه ونظر المشاهدات والمشاهدين
الى ان الامم المتحده تعرف الاغتصاب
الزوجي على انه ولوج مهبلي او شرجي او
فموي بطابع جنسي غير توافقي لجسم شخص اخر
بواسطه اي جسد جزء جسدي او باستخدام اداه
وكذلك اي اعمال اخرى غير توافقيه بطبيعه
جنسيه من قبل الزوج او الزوج السابق او
الشريك سابق او حالي تعيش معه ضحيه اغتصاب
او تعيش في شراكه يعترف بها القانون
الوطني اذا هناك قوانين اليوم في عده دول
في العالم تعترف بطابع الاغتصاب في العلا
في الاكراه في العلاقه انا يعني ما تفضلت
به ينطبق على اشخاص اسوياء ولكن اليوم
هناك اشخاص غير اسوياء يمكن ان يكونوا في
شراكه زوجيه وسؤالنا اليوم عن هؤلاء
الاشخاص سنعرض طبعا لاحقا ساعرض عليكم
مجموعه من من الشهادات التي رويت لنا خلال
الاعداد لهذه الحلقه ولكن اريد ان اتعرف
على ضيفتنا من تونس قبل ذلك واعود اليك
استاذ عصام والست فدو من تونس الكتوره
ايناس سليم المتخصصه في الطب الجنسي
وامراض الغدد والكاتبه العامه المساعده في
المكتب التنفيذي للجمعيه التونسيه للطب
الجنسي اهلا بك دكتوره بناء
على تجربتك بناء على تجربتك في مجال الصحه
الجنسيه تاتيك ربما
سيدات يعني تعرضنا للاكراه في المعاشره
الزوجيه ما يسمى اليوم بالاغتصاب الزوجي
ماذا تقولين عاده لسيده في هذه الحاله
يعني وكيف يعني وهل هذا هذا امر موجود
منتشر لان يعني هناك بعض الناس التي تعتبر
انه يعني غير موجود في الثقافات العربيه
ربما او الشرقيه نحب نحط الموضوع هذ في
اطار متها عام اللي هو الاغتصاب زمنا نفهم
اللي هو نوع يقعد نوع من انواع العنف ضد
المراه وهذا معناتها على حسب المنظمه
العالميه للصحه وكيما تقول سواء ارتكبه
شريك حميم او كان ذ طبيعه جنسيه ولا من
شخص بعيد لهنا اللي نحب ناكد عليه في
المساله هذ هو الضرر اللي يحصل للانسان ما
قلت انت احنا نجم نستقبل في العيادات اعنا
نساء يحكيو على الموضوع هذايا مش لمجرد
الحكايه ولكن باش يعرضوا الضرر اللي
حصلوه اثار نجم تكون جسديه تجم تكون
اثار نفسيه تنجم تكون اثار زده حتى على
الانجاب يعني احنا والضرر اللي ينجم يكون
موجود هذ هذ المشكل راه مشكل منتشر في
العالم اجمع وعلى حسب
المنظمه العالميه
للصحه مراه على ثلاثه تجم تعاني من هذا
المشكل من جانب شريك حميم والا من شخص اخر
ونشير من جانب شرك
حميم يعني النسبه اعلى من العباد الاخرين
دونك احصاءات تشير الى ان منتصف او اكثر
من نصف اكثر من نصف ال يعني جرائم
الاغتصاب تحصل داخل البيوت داخل العلاقات
الزوجيه يعني هذه احصاءات موجوده هنا
للاسف لم نتحصل على احصاءات من الدول
العربيه لان لان الجدل موجود كما تفضل
استاذ عصام منذ قليل وقال يعني
هناك شريحه كبرى من الحقوقيين وحتى من
رجال الدين ومن السياسيين الذين يرفضون
اطلاق تسميه اغتصاب زوجي على هذه الجريمه
اريد ان اسال فقط يعني ست فدوى في هذا
الشان اليوم ربما هناك الكثير من الناس
الذين يفضلون استخدام اكراه الزوجه على
المعاشره الجنسيه على اعتبار ان لا اختصاب
بين رجل وزوجته عندما يكون هناك عقد
زواج اولا في المغرب القانون الجنائي
بالمغرب في الماده 486 يعرف الاغتصاب انه
اجبار الرجل على مواقعه امراه دون
موافقتها دون ان يحدد ان كانت هذه المراه
زوجته او قريبته او في علاقه حميميه معه
او صديقه او ا كان بالتالي يعاقبه من خمس
الى 10 سنوات وبالتالي انا في نظري هذا
القانون هذا فصل القانون الجنائي في
المغرب حتى وان
كان يعني يسهل عمليه اثبات الاغتصاب الزوج
واعتبار ان اكراه الزوجه على المعاشره
الجنسيه احيانا تحت التهديد وتحت العنف
واحيانا بطرق لا توافق عليها الزوجه الى
انه وهذا سمح لمحكمه في مدينه النجه
بتطبيق هذا القانون على احد الازواج الى
انه رغم ذلك مازال
هناك اجهادات
قضائيه نعم اسمعك اجتهادات نعم نعم هناك
الشهادات قضائيه ولكنها لا
ترقى قد اقول انها محتشمه دعيني
اسال ضيفتنا التي انضمت الينا الان من
الكويت المحاميه ورئيسه مجموعه التحديات
القانونيه اريج عبد الرحمن اهلا بك سيده
اريج اعديتي دراسه كامله عن مساله
الاغتصاب الزوجي من اين اتى اهتمامك بهذا
الموضوع خاصه انه يعني ربما من البوهات
الاكبر اليوم في مساله الجنس بالتحديد
بالنسبه لي
مرت علي حاله بحكم اني انا اساسا محاميه
وناشطه في حقوق المراه ومرت علي هذه
الحاله في عام
2015 واستغربت جدا لمن جتني احد
الموكت وطلبت مني انها تبي ترفع قضيه على
زوجها لان
اغتصبها الفكره كانت غريبه بالنسبه لي
يعني انا اول مره اسمع فيها فبديت ابحث
لقيت لا الموضوع مستحق يستحق ان البحث فيه
والدراسه لانه اكتشفت انه ما كان في عقوبه
في قانون الكويت في عام 2015 يجرم
هذا النوع
من السلوك الاجرامي واللا انساني اللي هو
الاغتصاب الزوجي ولكن كان في عام 2015 مع
الاسف كان وقتها هذا النوع من السلوك يعني
فقط على المراه ان تطلب الطلاق
لضرر يعتبر اكراه في العلاقه الزوجيه ولا
يعتبر جريمه ولكن في عام
2020 نعم ايه تطلب الطلاق لضرر فقط يعني
يعتبر اكراه في العلاقه الزوجيه ولكن في
عام 2020 تم تشريع قانون الحمايه من العنف
الاسري و وفي في الماده الاولى منه في
التعريفات عرفوا العنف الاسري هو كل علاقه
تؤدي الى ضرر واذى لاحد الاشخاص طبعا اللي
بال الاسره اللي هم الاسره الزوج او
الزوجه الابناء والاحفاد يعني مدينها في
الماده وسواء كانت
العلاقه الضرر جسدي او نفسي او جنسي طيب
وبالتالي هني ممكن بعد ما تم تشريع هذا
القانون ممكن يدخل الاغتصاب الزوجي كعقوبه
تعتبر على الزوج بس الان ما انطرحت قضيه
بالمحاكم الكويتيه لم تطرح حتى الان هذا
هذا هذا ما سنتحدث معه ولكن قبل ذلك دعيني
ا الى القاهره مع الاستاذ عصام عجاج استاذ
عصام يعني اليوم هذا نقاش ربما يستحق
التعمق اكثر في مصر مثلا مؤخرا هناك قضيات
الضحيه التي عرفت بعروس الدقليه انتشرت
كثيرا فتاه تبلغ 24 عاما توفيت ليله عرسها
بعدما حاول الزوج فض غشاء البكاره كما
يقال فاصابها بنزيف حاد وتركها في المنزل
حتى فارقت الحياه في حاله كهذه يعني اليوم
في محضر النيابه في مصر لم يتم الحديث عن
اغتصاب زوجي لان ليس هناك هذه التسميه في
القانون المصري انما اقر القانون بانه
حاول اخذ ما وصفه بحقه الشرعي طب انت في
هذه الحاله كمحامي كشخص يعني قانوني هل
تعتبر ان
القانون يعني ينصف الضحايا ضحايا من هذا
النوع بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم بس انا عايز
ارجع برض لجزئ حضرتك تحدثت عنها الا وهي
تقرير الامم المتحده سنه 93 وان هو عرف
الاغتصاب الزوجي بهو كذا كذا برض برجع
وصمم بان انا معترض على كلمه الاغتصاب
الزوجي هذا امر الامر الاخر ان النهارده
اللي ينفع للامم المتحده في الدول الغرب
خليني اكمل خليني اكمل الفكره اللي ينفع
اللي ينفع في الدول الغرب
ودول الدول الاخرى لا ينفع في الدول
الشرقيه ليه احنا عندنا قوانين القوانين
نا بتقول ان ثمره الزواج هو هو لقاء الزوج
بزوجته وبالتالي لا يمكن انك انت تيجي
النهارده تعاقبيني على مجرد شيء او ثمره
من ثمرات الزواج بالنسبه لزوجتي الامر
الاخير كل المنادين وكل الناس اللي معانا
على الهوا دلوقتي اللي بيكلموا حضرتك و لا
ما انا جاي لحضرتك جميل قوي كلمه بدون
رضاء انا بس حط تحتيها 20 سطر وللناس اللي
هي اصلا معانا ضيوف في هذه الحلقه اللي
بينادوا بالاغتصاب الزوجي عمليه رضا
الزوجه باللقاء الحميمي او المعاشره
الجنسيه مع زوجها من الامور المستتره من
الامور المستتره اللي هي في الخفاء ما
تعرفهاش غير الزوجه قولي لي النهارده لو
جت الزوجه استخدمت الكيديه والانتقام
والتعسف ضد الزوج رغم موافقتها على اللقاء
ده وجت الصبح قالت ده تم غصب عني هنعمل
ايه انا عايزهم يجاوبوني هذا امر الامر
الاخر م بوك يلا بتفضل اقترح الامر الاخر
و لا لا اكمل اكمل اكمل اكمل بعد اذنك
سعادتك هذا امر النهارده انت وافقتي على
هذا اللقاء والصبح اشتكيني في بعضهم ممكن
يرد يقول لك ايه يقول لك في اثار باينه
عليها اثار ماديه لا الاكراه الاكراه على
هذه العمليه ممكن يكون مادي وممكن يكون
معنوي زي ممكن يكون غصب عنها وان انا الو
دراعها او ان انا اعمل ده غصب عنها ممكن
يكون باكراه معنوي ان انا اهدد بالحاق
الاذى بيه وبالتالي مش هيبقى في اثار
ماديه طيب انا النهارده كزوج شرقي هل انا
مطالب بان انا اخد اقرار منها كتابي على
ورقه بهذا الامر هل انا مطالب بان انا احط
كاميرا فوق غرف غرفه النوم فوق السرير
عشان ابري صحتي ده كلام من العبث ولا طيب
طيب هو يعني ساترك الضيفات اللي جبنا رب
ربما هكذا نفتح النقاش ابدا معك دكتوره
ايناس تفضلي مساله الكيديه تحدث عنها انت
يعني ربما
التقيت بسيدات تعرضنا لهذا الامر كيف
تردين على هذه على هذه نوافق نوافق في
مشكل اللي هو من الصعب جدا
كون
نعطيو شواهد والا يعني حاجات تثبت الصار
معناتها ما يسمى بالاغتصاب الجنسي داخل
الزواج هو اشكال كونه نصبته ما يلزم ينحي
المشكل في اصله صحيح معناتها فم مشكل في
كون المراه تثبت ولكن انا نحب نجاوب خونا
من مصر ق مذا بنا نحطوا هذا في اطار علاقه
كامله راه الزواج علاقه حميميه علاقه موده
علاقه رحمه هذ حتى في الدين اعنا ما نحكيو
الغرب والشرق هذ بصفه عامه حتى في ديننا
فم علاقه موده ورحمه يعني هذه باش تدخل
كون يصير موافقه هذا شيء طبيعي ولو كان
المراه يعني مش موافقه كتابيه لو كان
المراه في اول بدايه العلاقه الحميميه
نعرفوها اللي هي مع احنا ديما نفسه تكون
فيها بدايات
مداعبه فما ذلك لو كان المراه ماهيش حاضره
وقالت واضح قالت ليه ماهيش حاضره وقتها من
البديه وهذي احنا نقولها ديس يعني انسان
احترام جسد احترام الذات يفرض عليه باش
يحترم رايها ليه راه يه زده ممكن هذا با
يتقلق مني الاخ المصري اما را في بعض
الاحيان حتى الرجل ينجم يقول ليه ممكن
المراه وهه هي وهذا ياخذنا الى مبدا
الرضائيه ست فدوى يعني اليوم الى اي مدى
مساله مقاربه ما نسميه في هذه الحلقه
الاغتصاب الزوجي
متعلق مباشره بمبدا الرضائيه وربما هذا
المبدا الذي ينقص في بعض العقليات لكي
نفهم اكثر لماذا يسمى اغتصاب زوجي ربما
هذا هو هذه هي المشكله اولا يجب ان نرد
على صديقنا من مصر انه طلب ردودا نعم
الاقرار الكتابي والكاميرا فوق سرير تفضلي
ردي هذا ما
طلبه اذا نهج مسلك ان هناك جرائم لا يمكن
اثباتها فالامر قد يسري على جرائم كثيره
اغتصابات الاطفال لا يمكن اثباتها بما
انها تقع في السريه وفي اماكن لا اماكن
بعيده عن عيون الناس جرائم التحرش لا يمكن
ايضا اثباتها لانها تحدث في الاماكن
الخاصه هناك اليوم زين المحارم يجب ان
نعترف به و موجود ولا يمكن اثباته هناك
ايضا تحرش داخل الاساط لا يمكن اثباته وهل
الحل هو ان نضع الكاميرات في الشوارع ولكن
اليوم هناك ارقام تتحدث وتقول ان
من النساء اللواتي يشتكين من الاغتصاب او
من التحرش لا تكون شكايات كيديه لان كي
تصل المراه انها تفشي حياتها الحميميه صعب
حتى في الدول الاوروبيه وحتى في الدول
الغربيه يعني بما انها تخطوا هذه الخطوه
الا وتكون 90% او 99% من القضيه الصحيحه
هذا امر اول ثانيا ان الطب اليوم يمكن ان
يحدد ويمكن ان يكشف اذا كانت فعلا تلك
العلاقه تم في اجواء طبيعيه وعاديه او تحت
الاكراه الاذى من هذا لاكثر والافضل هو ان
عندما نتحدث عن الاغتصاب الزوجي خصوصا في
بد العالم الثالث فلا تكون فقط
اكراها لفظيا ولكنه في غالب الاحيان يكون
مصحوبا بالضر والتعنيف والحاق الاد بالات
حاده
واحيانا
بربط النساء وبسلوك
سلوك
عنيف بسيط جدا اثباته
نعم المؤسف في حياه في حياه النساء في هذه
الدول هو ان الزواج يعتبر بما انك تقبلين
بالزواج بهذا الشخص او ان مجرد عقد زواجك
بشخص ما فهو موافقه مستمره في الزمان وفي
مكان على العلاقه الحميم في حين ولكن هناك
اعذار يعني قدمت قدمت طبعا يعني اليوم
الاديان تتفق على انه واجب للمراه ان يعني
ان تنام مع زوجها كما يقال بالعاميه ولكن
هناك ايضا الاعذار الشرعيه التي يمكن
للمراه ان تقدمها للزوج منها مساله الحيض
او المرض وامور
اخرى هل هل يكفي هذا الامر يعني ساسال هذا
السؤال للسيده اريج عبد الرحمن حميده هل
يكفي هذا الامر اليوم هل يكفي ان يكون
للمراه اعذار شرعيه لكي يعني لا تقع ضحيه
غصب او اغتصاب او اكراه على علاقه جنسيه
في الزواج طبعا بالنسبه حق العلاقه
الزوجيه هي علاقه تعاقديه تتتم بالرضا بين
الطرفين ولا وهي مو بس فقط خاصه بالعلاقه
الجنسيه هي العلاقه الجنسيه تعتبر جزء من
كثير من الالتزامات بين الزوج والزوجه
العلاقه الزوجيه العلاقه الجنسيه التي تتم
بين الزوجين يجب ان تتم بالرضا هذا في
القانون وفي الشريعه الاسلاميه ايضا يعني
حتى الشريعه الاسلاميه تلزم الزوج ان
يعاملها بالحب والود وان يحافظ على
كرامتها وهذه موجوده بالايات القرانيه و
وبالاحوال الكريم بخصوص كيف يتم الاثبات
هي فعلا علاقه الجنسيه اللي بين الزوجين
تتم بالخفاء وليست بالعلن ولكن اذا بمسك
مساله الكيديه فترى مساله الكيديه ممكن
تكون موجوده في جميع انواع القضايا مو بس
به القضيه فلذلك اني انا احرم المراه من
ان هي تحافظ على كرامتها بحجه والله يمكن
تكيدين هذا الكلام طبعا منطق انا بالنسبه
لي ارفضه كيف نثبت الاثبات سهل مو صعب لما
يتم هناك طبعا بس عشان قبل اتكلم عن عمليه
الاثبات خلينا نعرف شنو هي شنو هو
الاغتصاب الزوجي الاغتصاب الزوجي
هو ان يتم اللاج
بطريقه فيها عنف استخدام العنف وهذا طبعا
الامر يتم اثباته عن طريق الطبيب الشرعي
نعم الطبيب الشرعي يقدر يثبت كثير من
حالات العنف اللي تتم بجسد المراه صحيح
والمراه من حقها ان هي تدافع عن جسدها
مساله ان الزوج حر لا الزوج حر ولكن هناك
قيود على حريته في التعامل الجنسي فاحنا
ما نتكلم بس عن انه والله ممكن يكون فيها
حاله الحيظ احنا نتكلم عن حاله التعذيب
هناك رجال يعانون من مرض نفسي ما يعرف
يمارس العلاقه الجنسيه
ويصل للمرحله اللي يبيها الا بالتعذيب
فهني احنا نتكلم عن الاغتصاب الزوجي اللي
هو تعذيب المراه وهذا طبعا فعل مجر يعني
ساعرض علي
وعليكم يعني كان من الصعب جدا ان نجد
سيدات يقبلنا ان يتحدثن عن هذه التجارب
لان غالبيه السيدات اللوات تعرضنا لتجربه
من هذا النوع بدون كيديه طبعا استاذ عصام
يعني من الصعوبه ان يتحدثن احدى السيدات
كتبت لي وقالت انا تعرضت لهذا الامر وصار
عندي اذى نفسي وجسدي وتم اغتيالي نفسيا
حتى من قبل اهلي وعندما تحدثت الى اهلها
عن الموضوع قالوا لها بانها سيئه يعني
انها زوجه سيئه حتى انها ذهبت وقصدت الشيخ
اي الامام وقالت له ماذا يعني ماذا يحصل
في فراشها الزوجي فقال لها ان هذا واجبها
وانها يجب ان ترضي زوجها والا ستكون ناشز
انت برايك استاذ عصام اليوم في هذه
الحالات اليس من الضروري ان يكون القانون
موجود لحمايه سيده ربما يعني في حاله كما
تفضلت السيده اريج وقالت امام شخص مريض او
يعاني من من انحراف معين في سلوكه الجنسي
او مؤذي
او
افضل هو ليه بس بعد اذن حضرتك الامم
المتحده منزعجه لهذا الامر بدليل انها
افردت ليه في العنف ضد المراه يعني عايز
اقول بنود وبنود هو ليه ان الضيوف اللي مع
سعادتك كلهم يتحدثوا عن هذا الامر وليه
انتم عايز اقول
بتغد طيب ما انا هقول لحضرتك بتغد الطرف
عن عن عن بالمسمى اللي انتم بتسموه اغتصاب
زوجي للرجال يعني بيقع على الرجال او على
الاقل نقدر نسميه ابتزاز زوجي بمعنى ان
الراجل ممكن يكون عايز يقيم العلاقه
الحميميه الست تبتز ماديا تبتز ماديا ودي
جريمه ولكن اليوم انت لماذا يعني لماذا
تصر على ان تقول الموضوع ليس ضد الرجال يا
سيد عصام يعني نحن لسنا هنا نحاكم الرجال
نحن نسالك كرجل قانون اليوم انت يجب تدافع
عن رجال ونساء نعم تفضل طب اسمعيني انا
انا هرجع انا هرجع لجزء تاني خالص
اولا الداعيه الاسلامي اللي هي كلمته وقال
لها هذا الامر انت تعتبري ناشذ او خلافه
هو حضرتك ليه مش قادره تعرفي بان كل
مجتمعاتنا العربيه بتقول ان النهارده قد
يكون ذلك اللقاء الحميمي واجب على الزوجه
خلي بالك واجب على الزوجه حتى لو هي مش في
موت كويس امتى اذا كان من القصد من ذلك
اعفاف الزوج عن الوقوع في الحرام كلنا تؤ
هذا العمل للزوج شيخ علي جمعه من الازهر
في مصر خل قال ان ان خل اكمل كلام خليني
اكمل كلامي ه بعد اذنك استاذه ميسه استاذه
ميسه تفضل انا بقارن دلوقتي بواز بين
امرين الاذى النفسي الواقع عليها عدم
اقامه العلاقه عشان مده مش كويس وبين ان
زوج يقع في كبيره من الكبائر واحنا مجتمع
شرقي اللي ينفع عندنا ما ينفعش عندكم في
الغرب بمعنى يعني في حمل قبل الزواج في
الغرب في مثليه جنسيه مش موجوده عندنا في
خروج الزوجه بدون اذن زوجها موجود كل
الحاجات دي مش موجوده عندنا فاللي ينفع
المجتمع الغرب غير اللي ينفع عندنا والا
كده هتبقى كل المجتمعات الشرقيه يجب وفقا
لهذا المنظور انها تكون منبطحه للغرب خاصه
ان ادمور شرعيه ان كل الدول العربيه لم
تجرب بالنسبه اليك هو نظريه غربيه غير
موجود في مجتمعات مجتمعات تسميها انت
شرقيه لا ادري لماذا تكلم عنها الازهر في
هذه الحاله لو لم تكن موجوده ولكن تفضلي
دكتوره تحفظ تفضل د وانا وانا وان وصل
التحفظ انا يعني لن اقدم لست هنا لاقدم
راي تفضل تفضل تفضل ع ثواني اديني 10
ثواني انا بقول تحفظ ايه لست مع ان الزوج
يكره زوجته على ذلك اللقاء الحميمي بمعنى
يجب ان يكون هناك موده ورحمه وذلك ان ان
هذا ممنوع في في الحيط ممنوع في النفاس
ممنوع في في نهار رمضان الامور دي كلها
مفروض بعيد عن هذا برض لازم يكون مود
الزوجه كويس مزاجها كويس لكن اذا تم هذا
زي ما حضرتك بتقولي تل للطلاق لكن ما عقبش
الزوج ان انا احبسه ان انا اسميه اغتصاب
زوجي دكتوره ايناس كنت تريدين ان تقولي
شيئا ما لاستاذ عصام على ما يبدو يعني
تفضلي حبيت اشير المشكل علاش فم مشكل وهو
مش قادر يتبعنا في في الموضوع على خاطر
نحسوا فم جانب من السيطره هو اصلا كلمه
اغتصاب كما نقولوا لها بالفرنسيه فم
دومينا سيون فم ان دومينو وثم حد باش يكره
على فعل شيء مسيطر ومكره نعم تفضلي وهذا
هو اساس المشكل يعني لو ناخذ مبدا احنا
المساوات واللي هو مبدا حق راه ماهوش ميزه
ما تنجمش تقوللي انت للمراه لو كان هي في
مود خايب لا يكره عليها لنا ثم اكراه
طبيعي باش تكون المراه حتى بمشاغل بتعبها
تكون في بعض الاحيان مود ولكن احنا هنا
نقولوا الزواج يقام على معناتها على
الجماع نحكيو بصفه عامه بصفه عامه ولكن
وقتيا في بعض الحالات المراه لا تكون
حاضره باش باش
تقوم معناتها معناتها بالعلاقه الجنسيه مش
في الموت كما قال استاذ عصام يعني لا رغبه
لديها لا رغبه لديها ذاك عيش نرجعوا
نقولوا لتفادي احنا مش مش نوصل للطلاق هو
قال لو كان هي ما تحبش تطلق عليه فم مراحل
قبل الطلاق فم التحاور ف الكلام ت احنا
قلنا موده ورحمه معها يعني انت كان تسمعني
وطبق نقول اوكي ماطبق نطلق عليه ف تحاور ف
مختصين ينجموا يعاونوا لو كان ف امور
تعودت والرغبه مش موجوده ف مبدا موافقه
يلزمنا نحترمو هذ جانب انساني را مبدا
الريه طيب دكتوره دعيني اسال ست فدوى يعني
اليوم اشار الاستاذ عصام الى نقطه مهمه
جدا في هذا النقاش نقراها كثيرا عندما
نبحث هناك من يقول يا ست فدوى نحن في قمه
الاستغراب من اثاره مثل هذه المواضيع
لماذا نتتبع العورات لماذا ندخل الغرف
المغلقه فالعلاقه الزوجيه من ادق ومن اكثر
العلاقات سريه بين الزوجين لماذا ننبش في
قبور
الزوجيه اولا نحن ل لا ندخل الغرف المقفله
هي من يخرج عندنا النساء هنا لواتي يبحثن
ويراسلني شكين مما ي داخل هذه الغرف نحن
اليوم فقط نحاول ايصال هذه الاصوات ل
للمشرعين كي يسن قوانين مناسبه لهذه هكذا
حوادث اذا مشكله الغرب فقط بالنسبه كما
قال استاذ
عصام نهائيا المشكله عندنا احنا في
الدول الشرق الاوسط في شمال افريقيا هي
تمثلات هنا للجنس اليوم الكل يتحدث عن
رغبه الرجل التي لا يمكن كبها الاستاذ
عصام قال بالحرف ماذا سيفعل هل يقع في
الحرام الهذه الدرجه لهذه الدرجه فعلا
تكون هذه الرغبه عند الرجل الي لا يمكن
كبحها او الانتظار او ربما التساؤل لماذا
هذه السيده اليوم العلاقه الجنسيه هل نحن
بصدد التعامل مع انسان ام مع حيوانات
اعتذر عن هذا الل اذا هناك تملات تعتبر ان
النساء لا يشهي وبالتالي لا يمكن ان يرفض
نا دميات جسيه تنتظر فقط ان ياتي الرجل
يطلب منها ان يمارس معها الجنس وهذا امر
غلط نساء ايضا لهنا رغبات جنسيه يفضلن بعض
الامور ولا يفضل اخرى قد يكنا متعبات في
قال هو ما عندهاش
المود الممارسه العلاقه الجنسيه السؤال
الذي يجب ان بحده هو
لا يمكن ان نعالج الاغتصاب الزوجي بالطلاق
وكانك تقول ان فلان تر الحل هو ان نسامحه
ان نتجاوز او على المسروق في ان السرقه
حتى لرج المسروق تستوجب العقوبه ان جريمه
الاغتصاب الزوجي جريمه اليوم عندما تاتيك
امراه
معنفه بهامات في الجسد ديالها جروح مرس
عليها الجنس بالقوه
بالعنف كل اثار العنف يعني واضحه على
جسدها ثم تخبرها الح سيدتي هو ان تتطلق
طيب هي طبعا ستق من زوجك هذا الفكره وصلت
الفكره اذا بالنسبه اليك انت يعني اليوم
هذا الامر جريمه والحل ليس فقط في الطلاق
اريد ان اسمع راي السيده اريش تفضلي سيده
اريج يعني اليوم هناك اراء موجوده في
مجتمعاتنا تعتبر ان هذا ننوع من النقاش
ربما يعني لا يجب ان يثار بهذه الطريقه في
المجتمعات العربيه كيف تجيبين وهل تعتبرين
ان الحل هو الطلاق او التجريم طبعا احنا
يعني وصلنا لمرحله
من التفتح والثقافه والفهم فمو معقول
اليوم احنا في عام 2023 نقول لا نطرح هذه
القضيه هناك الكثير من القضايا الحساسه
اذا كانت حالات استثنائيه يجب تسليط الضوء
عليها اعلاميا حتى يتم مكافحتها ولا تصل
لمرحله الظاهره فلذلك تسليط الضوء عليها
يخلي القياديين في الدول يبتدون يشرعون
قوانين يكافحون هذا النوع من السلوك
بالنسبه الى ردا وتعقيبا على الاستاذ
الفاضل بخصوص ان ليش تقولون اغتصاب زوجي
ضد الرجل ولا تتكلمون ضد المراه انا احب
اكد ان احنا عندنا مثلا قانون اليوم
بالكويت اللي هو قانون العنف الاسري رقم
16 لعام 2020 تكلم عن العنف الاسري بان هو
مثل ما قلت مساعه العلاقه الجنسيه ولكن لم
يفرق يعني ما ما كان هذا القانون خاص فقط
لحمايه المراه من الع لحمايه الاسره بما
فيها
الزوج ينطبق على الرجل وعلى طبعا ينطبق
على الكل حتى كذلك القانون الفرنسي لما
شرع قانون واضح عام
1994 شرع هل زوجين الرجل والمراه فهذه
المساله لما نتكلم عن احنا قاعدين نتكلم
عن
هنا ان هذا الامر لا يكفي يعني ان الامر
هذا لا يكفي هو فعلا القانون موجود بس صعب
على المراه انها تروح وتطلع وتقول ان زوجي
اغتصبني لان هذا دائما تلاقينها تفكر
باولادها باطفالها بعيالها انه لما يكبرون
شلون بعدين الوضع والله الا الام تطلقت
لان الاب اغتصب الزوج فهذا راح ياثر عليه
ام ها المشكله يعني طبعا اكيد فصعب اساسا
انه تطلع انا اقوللك القانون عندنا من
2020 لكن الى اليوم ما سمعت ان هناك حاله
اغتصاب زوجي كقضيه طرحت بالمحاكم طيب
استاذ عسام حتى الحالتين اللي يوني يعني
يبون يبون يعاقبون الزوج بس ما نبي نقول
نعم بدون ان يتحدثن عن تفاصيل استاذ عصام
عندي سؤال لك اخير لانه الوقت خلص ايه
ساقرا ساقرا عليك يعني شهاده لسيده لو اتت
هذه السيده اليك كمحام لاجئه اليك ماذا
تنصحها تقول كل ما كنت اقول تعبانه مش
قادره من العيال وشغل البيت كان يقول لي
انت مش هتشمي ريحه الجنه ولا هتدخليه
علشان تقولي لجوزك لا وبعد كل الاهانات
والاتهامات دي برض ما كانش بيهتم بكلامي
وكان بيعمل معايا العلاقه بالغصب انت
كمحامي في حال جاءتك سيده وقالت لك هذا
الامر ماذا تنصحه شوفي حضرتك لازم احنا
نخلي كل واقعه لاسلوب تحاور زوجي كل حاله
لوحدها بمعنى ما نعمم العلاقات هذه يعني
عايز اقول حاله فرديه بتحاول تقنع زوجها
بالحسنى وتقول له ما ينفعش ده والله اذا
تضررت وتضررت من هذا الامر وكان مصر على
عناده القانون عندنا مثلا على سبيل المثال
في مصر اعطاها 10 حالات للطلاق منها
الطلاق للضرر في هذه الحال
بس انا عايز ارجع تاني واقول سؤال لكل
الساده الضيوف اللي معانا حضراتكم
النهارده
بتؤم الاغتصاب الزوجي تقدروا بقى تردوا
عليا في السؤال اللي انا بساله نفترض ان
الزوجه وافقت على هذا اللقاء الحميمي
بينها وبين زوجها وفرضنا عملنا اللي هو
عايز اقول اللي ما ينفعش يتعمل الغير
منطقي ان انا خدت منها اقرار كتابي
بالموافقه وده مش هيحصل طيب افترض الصبح
قالت لا لقاء تم رغما عني والاقرار اللي
انا كتبته دوت او اللي انا وقعت بان انا
موافقه ده هو اكرهن عليه سعبه يا استاذ
عصام ماذا يفعل الزوج يعني يعني يعني هن
اصلا هن اصلا لا يتحدثن في هذا الاصل
اوصل استاذه ميسه استاذه ميسه اديني اديني
اديني جزء من الحوار عشان اوصل المعلومه
زوجتي دلوقتي وافقت وافقت والصبح اشتكتني
ولقيت نفسي قدام المحكمه يبقى انا مافيش
قدامي غير حل واحد فقط الناس اللي هم
الضيوف اللي معاكي عايزين يوصلوني ليه يا
اما احط كاميرا تاني فوق غرفه النوم عشان
اثبت ان اللقاء كان برضاء تام منها يا اما
كتبها اقرار واوثقه كمان في شهر العقاري
مش مجرد ادين فرصه يا اما يا اما هل لا
استنيني يا اما الجا للعلاقات المحرمه
واكون ارتكبت كبيره طيب وصلت فكرتك يعني
سادع الكلمه ل
دكت تفضلي ست اريش باختصار شديد 30 ثانيه
30 ثانيه معك تفضلي يلا لانه بدي اخلص
الحاله اللي ذكرها قاعد تمر علينا في
المحكمه في قضايا كثير وما يكون في اثبات
ولا يكون في كاميرا مسجله فيقوم القاضي
يوجه اليمين الحاسمه يعني هذه اخر اخر
الحالات اللي ممكن يتم اتباعها في المحكمه
شكرا لك دكتور ايناس كلمه اخيره في هذا
الموضوع تفضلي قبل ما اختم معك فدوى لحظه
يعيشك نشكرك على الاستضافه والكلمه
الاخيره بش نقول قي لاحظنا مع مشاركه
اخونا من مصر ق القوانين مش كافيه يعني هي
مشكله ثقافيه والمشكله الثقافيه احسن شيء
كونها تتحل بالوقايه معنتها يعني احنا
كجمع تونسيه للطب الجنسي من اهم المهام
اعنا هو التثقيف الجنسي كونه
الصغار والادول سون والكل اللي يبداو ي
صحيت
والمراهقين من اول السن يفهموا ش معنتها
مبدا الموافقه المتبادله يفهموا شش معنتها
عندي الحق باش نقول اي ولا لا وعندي ويلزم
الجواب اعي باي ولا لا يق يكون فم احترام
فيه يعني هذا لو كان يكبر به مادش با تصير
مشكله في الزوجين على خاطر مش باش نوصل
انا نفرض عليك وبعد انت تشكي بيا بالمحكمه
لا طيب ست ف شكرا لك دكتوره شكرا لك ست
فدوه تفضلي كلمه اخيره لو سمحت اعقد اننا
اجبنا عن سؤال عصام غير ما مره واخبرنا ان
تخوفات من الافتراء لا تلغي ان هناك جرائم
يجب ان يعاقب عليها القانون هنا قد شبهه
الافتراء لا تتجاوز
0.5% في حين ان ان حالات الاغتصاب الزوجي
التي تتم كثيره ومتعدده والدليل عليها هو
اجداد النساء التي تاتي معنفه عليها كل
اثار الضرب والج السؤال الذي تطرحه ماذا
سنفعل في هذه الحاله ما هي العقوبه التي
يجب ان تترتب عن تعنيف الزوجه من اجل
ممارسه جنسيه اما السؤال عن الافتراء فقد
اجبنا عنه وقلنا ان اصلا النساء لا يتجر
على فتح هذا النوع من الجرائم وان فعلنا
ذلك فيكون في الحالات القصوى التي يكون
العنف فيها ظاهرا
والتي اليوم الطب شكرا لك شكرا لكل
الضيفات وللضيف من القاهره خلص الوقت
للاسف يا استاذ عصام ان شاء الله في حلقات
مقبله يعني نتحدث اكثر عن هذا المواضيع عن
هذا الموضوع ومواضيع اخرى اريد فقط ان
اوجه تحيه للسيده اخبرتنا قصتها فيما
يتعلق بالاغتصاب الزوجي واريد ان اقول
انها تجربه كانت كما تصفها يعني قتلتها
نفسيا واختلت حتى انها بعد ان اخبرتنا
قصتها قالت لنا ساذهب لاستحم لكي ازيل عني
وسخ هذه الذكريات ال مؤلمه النقاش في فلك
الممنوع لا نهايه له نترك لك ولك حريه
الاختيار وحريه التفكير تابعونا في حلقات
جديده دائما على شاشه فرونس ان ك واثير
اذاعه مونتي كارلو الدوليه
تحياتي